Just the mention of his name can send a chill up the spine in a place full of
horror.
He was the most feared monster of the mall.
We're of course talking about the angel of death,
Josef Mengele,
although trained as a doctor to preserve life,
he brought a sadistic cruelty to the experiments that ended the lives of so many
and as victims of choice when they were children.
And this week's biographics,
we reveal the to pray of life of the monster of Auschwitz.
Doctor Yosef Mangola
yes of Mengele entered the welds on the 16th of March,
1911 and the German Bavarian town of Greensburg after three miscarriages.
He was the first born of coal as well purge and Mengele color was the owner of a
farm machine factory,
which tend to producing munitions.
When war broke out in 1914 the Manga lawyers would go on to have two more sons,
but Joseph was the firm favorite of his mother.
While Pogo was an obese woman who had a stern reputation and a voracious
appetite.
She doted on her eldest son and was much closer to him than she wants to.
Our husbands for his pass.
Yossef proved to be a quiet child whose main goal was to pleased as overbearing
mother at school Yosef.
He was an average students be struggled to keep his grades up at the standard
that is mother expect us and it's when he was 15 he contracted the serious bone
marrow disease osteomyelitis.
The disease which was often fatal in those days,
kept him off school for six months resenting to class.
He was seriously behind his peers academically over the next two years,
he showed a remarkable level of self discipline to not only catch up but surpass
many of his fellow students.
By the age of 17 he had outgrown his shyness and developed into a handsome
focused and driven young man who was popular with both teachers and classmates.
In April,
1930 the 19 year old passed his high school exams and gained acceptance into the
medical and philosophy faculties at Munich University.
He had decided to become a doctor.
Mengele stood out from the other men on campus.
He was always impeccably dressed and had developed the bear of a gentlemen,
be treated women with old fashioned dignity and was a very good dancer.
All these streets has got him quickly noticed by the ladies with the results
that is social calendar was usually pretty full.
During his first year of university,
Manga began to show an interest in politics.
He joins the steel helmets in March of 1931 a paramilitary group who advocated a
return to the prewar monarchy.
The steel helmets were a stepping stone and the national socialist or Nazi
party,
which was promoted in beer halls as well as on university campuses.
Then Nancy advocated a return of German pride and pure innocence,
the removal of racial impurities.
These ideas,
they appealed to Mengele and it seemed to Mesh with the social Darwinism that he
thought was being taught in the lecture halls.
He became fascinated with eugenics,
particularly the idea that the population could made more perfect through
selective breeding of those who had the most desirable characteristics.
It would also help to weed out undesirable traits by the elimination of the weak
and the feeble.
Hmm.
While the Nazis believed in Eugenics for them,
the process of generational selective breeding,
it was too slow.
They were determined to weed out the weak.
Right now,
the Aryan race could simply no longer stands being contaminated by inferior
races such as the Slavs and the Jews,
both of whom were considered into men's sure subhuman.
These beliefs were enthusiastically embraced by the young and impressionable
Josef Mengele.
In 1935 Mengele was awarded a phd in anthropology.
His thesis was entitled Racial Morphological Research on the lower jaw section
of for racial groups.
The people was free of any racial bias and set out to prove empirically by
science alone that the German was of superior breeding and about a human being.
Yeah.
Later man.
Hello.
Graduated with a medical degree.
He's been four months as an intern at Leipzig University clinic before joining
the staff of Germany's leading racial experts.
This was doctor Omar free,
her von [inaudible],
and he was based at the Institute for heredity biology and racial purity located
at the University of Frankfurt.
Mangle.
His job at the institute was to examine people who are suspected of breaking the
Nuremberg laws to see whether or not they were Jews.
He and his colleagues created thousands of files which would turn out to be
devastating in future years when people were rounded up for transportation to
concentration camps.
In May of 1937 Mengele officially joined the Nazi party.
He became a member of the Nazi Doctors Party and then in May of 1938 the short
staffing or assets,
the assets had been created as his personal protection squad,
but it expanded its role to the running of concentration camps.
The leader of the SS was Heinrich Himmler,
a meticulous organizer who had plans to make these still small organization as
powerful as the national army.
At the time,
Mengele joined the SS was an elite group,
but only allows the best specimens of area and manhood into its racks.
Yeah.
At about the same time as he became a member of the ss man.
Hello became engaged to Irene showing by the daughter of a professor at
Frankfurt University six years younger than Joseph.
Irene was a blond haired beauty and made deep perfect compliments to the
handsome athletic looking young docs up when it came to getting married.
However,
that was a bit of a problem.
While Yosef was able to show documentation of his area and purity,
Irene could not prove that her grandfather was 100% area.
It was only the influence of the Mengele family that it smoothed the way for the
wedding,
which took place in July of 1939 the failure to fully prove I reads ancestry
precluded the main from inclusion in the kinship book of the SS,
which included couples.
You could prove that area in ancestry back to 1715 as a result of Mengele was
deprived of the swords and spoons ward,
which was given to an ss man on the birth of a child.
After just three months of marriage,
Mangalo was cooled for a three month stint in the army.
He was sent to the tyrolean mountain region possessing a high level of physical
fitness and being an adapt Hika.
He excels in his service having completed his three months service.
He returned to his job at Frankfurt University,
but with the coming of war in 1939 national mobilization was instituted.
Mangola was rejected on the first draft because he had had a kidney infection.
It's a child
in June of 1948 main hello.
It was finally calls up becoming a second leftenant in the Waffen ss.
He was putting into no combat position working in the logical section of the
race and resettlement office.
By June of 1941 with the onset of Operation Barbarossa,
there was an urgent need for men to serve on the eastern front.
Mengele was pulled out of the office and sent to the Russian France.
He proved to be a courageous soldier winning the Iron Cross.
Second class at the beginning of 1942 Mengele transferred to the Scandinavian
Viking ss division where he served as a field doctor.
Again,
he proved his courage under fire winning the iron cross first class when he
pulled two men from a burning tank in November of 1942 he suffered serious
wounds and was taken off the front lines.
After a period of recovery,
he returned to do the race and reassessment office.
He gains a promotion to captain and then in mid 1943 was given what was to him a
dream job.
This was a practical eugenics research at this man that he was able to indulge
all of the wackiest eugenics theories,
testing them out on living human subjects.
Yeah,
the human subjects who would be mangled as Guinea pigs,
where to be found at the Auschwitz Birkenau concentration camp.
The obtains a posting to the camp and set about extending his anthropological
research into heredity.
Mengele was not the first doctor to use concentration camp inmates for research
purposes and and volts and to cow Jews were injected with bacteria exposed to
all manner of deadly diseases and struck with rifle butts repeatedly to see how
long it would take for them to suffer irreversible brain damage at Auschwitz
itself.
Dr Horst Schumann had been conducting sterilization experiments once castrating
19 men in a single day.
Yes.
Manolo was to take the scope and is barbarity of his experiments to an entirely
new level.
Auschwitz had been elected as the venue for his work because of it's out of the
way location and because it was close to where railway junction with tracks
coming from all over Europe.
Mangler arrived at Auschwitz on the 23rd of May,
1943 the next day he participated in his first selection.
This involved selecting which of the new inmates are rivals,
which to live in,
which were to die.
On that day alone,
he sent 1035 Gypsies to the gas chamber as it as his nature Manga was impeccably
dressed.
During these selections,
he wore a white as medical uniform,
white gloves and polished black boots.
His face was this,
as he decided who was to die by a flick of his wrist,
his constant chain smoking and it's era of nonchalance presented a mystifying.
Yes.
Terrifying sites for the bewildered new arrivals.
During his time at Auschwitz Mengele oversaw selection on 74 transports,
80% of new arrivals were condemned to death immediately.
All Children under the age of 14 were killed.
As with the old and the infirm Mengele.
It seemed to enjoy this aspect of his job and he was known to say,
here are the Jews enter through the doors and leave through the chimney.
Mangola his passion,
however,
was for scientific research.
He instructed the gods to seek out those who were deformed,
overly tall midgets,
or he were lame.
His most prized subjects were twins,
especially if they were children.
From his earliest days that university Mengele had a fascination with twins.
He believed that by studying them,
he could discover the secret to genetic manipulation.
Indeed,
it was his search for twins that motivated him to attend so many arrivals
selections.
During his time at Auschwitz,
he managed to find 1,500 pairs of twins that were used as human Guinea pigs.
Only 100 pounds survived.
The twins and other research subjects who were selected on arrival would be
marched to living quarters at the birth canal and about two miles away there.
They lived in appalling conditions surrounded by rotting corpses and starving
adults once established and they're disgraceful living quarters,
the children and had to complete an intensive questionnaire in which they have
to indicate their age,
height,
eye and hair color,
ethnic backgrounds,
as well as any health problems.
All the children assisted young ones to complete the forms,
desperate to have everything completed to the satisfaction of the gods.
Children would then be interviewed by Mangola himself who would take extensive
notes and then have a file for each child drawn up.
He was determined to have his research seen as legitimate and so we went to
great lengths to keep everything official in preparation for experimentation.
The children were cleaned,
bathed,
and dressed in clean pajamas.
They were then taken by Red Cross vehicles to one of has research laboratories.
He had established a number of labs around the Auschwitz Birkenau area for the
specific purposes.
At one blood tests and x rays were taken here.
The children were treated with Cat Mengele would come in regularly to make sure
that none were being mistreated.
On these occasions,
he would hand out sweets to the children and talk gently and reassuring the to
them.
By doing this,
he was able to engender trust,
which got the children onto this experimentation table
and other labs.
The most heinous barbarism was taking place on a daily basis.
Anesthesia,
it was never used,
so the pain that was inflicted on the children can hardly even be imagined.
Experiments included the removal of specific organs or limbs.
Immersion in freezing water,
the injection of dyes into the eyes,
the castration of boys,
sterilization of girls,
and deliberate infection of wounds with gangrene.
Occasionally Mangalo we'd organize endurance test experiments.
This involved subjects being given increasingly strong voltages of electricity
until they either died,
became unconscious or went into a coma.
As soon as the twin died,
it's sibling would immediately be killed in order to provide comparative data
during the autopsies display mangle his attempts to cloak his work in
legitimacy.
There was no valid scientific reason for any of these horrendous experiments.
Doctors who assisted Mengele later recorded that it seemed as if many of the
experiments were just inspired purely by sadism.
In addition to his diabolical lab work and to selection duties with new
arrivals,
Mangola occasionally delivered babies,
women who were found to be pregnant and were immediately gassed.
However,
if they were near full term,
Mangalo would deliver the baby only to be sent with its mother to death.
One of his greatest amusements was to allow for them both to live for some time
but to take the mother's breasts so that she would be forced to watch a baby
starve to death of all of his atrocities.
The worst occurred when he had a pit dug and a massive file it and the yard of
Birkenau.
He then had 300 children all under the age of five thrown into the flames.
Unlike the majority of Nazi killers,
Mengele did not have to be drugged or drunk in order to carry out his murderous
work.
In fact,
according to Jewish survivors who were forced to assist in the laboratories,
he was enthusiastic and it's infliction of cruelty.
At times,
his temper would flare and exhibit itself with sharp bursts of horror.
On one occasion,
he smashed an old man's skull open simply because he wanted to be on his son's
work.
Detail within the camps of Auschwitz and Birkenau,
Mengele had unlimited power.
This combines with this natural sadism,
turns him into a monster.
He was often in the company.
It's on his rounds by his female equal ss Goddamn aggressor at 21 year old
blonde beauty,
who was almost as depraved as he was.
The two of them marched around the camp and immaculate uniform,
the perfect area,
and couple mangle his hatred for the Jews.
It knew no bounds.
He would celebrate Jewish holy days such as Yom Kippor by ordering the gassing
of a thousand children,
but as extreme prejudice could not prevent feelings of lust from arising within
him.
On occasion when naked young women were paraded in front of him.
On one occasion,
a beautiful 15 year old Jewish girl from Transylvania stood in front of him.
Mengele was clearly aroused by the girl,
obviously torn inside you and the girl selected for special experimentation over
the next hour.
He caused such deformity to our body that she resembles an old decrepit hag.
He then left her to die having overcome his illicit lust.
By early 1944 Mengele had taken to adopting a child in variably the little boy
would physically resemble him and we'd be dressed in a small white medical
uniform.
Mengele would walk around the camp,
hands in hands with a child providing him with suites and ties.
Within a month the doctor would tire of the child's and let him still hand in
hand to the gas chamber.
The crueler than Mengele was in the conducting of his duty is the more respect
he got in the Nazi hierarchy.
In a report written at the end of 1944 Auschwitz camp commandants Rudolph Hess,
right to that Mengele carried out all tasks,
evens him often under very difficult conditions to the complete satisfaction of
his superiors.
Often using his little off duty time to utilize the scientific material that is
disposal to make valuable contributions.
You anthropological science.
By early 1945 Mengele was at the height of his power.
Yes.
You could also read the writing on the wall.
He knew that the war was seemed lost and that the Russians would overrun the
camp.
In early January,
the Crematoria had been blown up and healthy prisoners were being forced,
marched in new destinations in Germany,
and I got to let continued his experiments until the last minute,
but then he busied himself and shipping out all of his equipment,
documents and reports.
Then on January the 17th of 1945 Josef Mengele simply disappeared from
Auschwitz.
10 days later,
the Russians arrived.
They discovered a burnt out horror factory.
The place had been set on fire and the Germans like Mengele had flat,
a few thousand survivors more dead than alive.
We're fountains wandering among the ruins.
Mengele had flesh to another concentration camp further south.
Then as the Russians closed in on that camp,
he made for the math housing camp in Austria.
When the allies approached,
he ditched his Nazi uniform and went on the run.
It's freedom.
It didn't last long.
On May the second he had joined up with a war hospital units.
The unit soon was overrun by the Russians and all the Germans were taken into
custody.
When arrested Mengele was wearing a we're marked uniform.
He proved to be about prisoner constantly worrying that he would be exposed as
an SS officer.
We've all,
if the suspected ss men we did out,
he and the other prisoners were handed over to the Americans and then released.
The Angel of death appeared to have escaped scottfree.
However,
he knew he would be constantly hunted down.
He was too afraid to return to his family,
so he traveled around West Germany and into Soviet occupied East Germany for
three years.
He worked as a laborer on an Alpine farm in Bavaria.
Meanwhile,
the story of mangle his atrocities had been revealed to the world at large.
As a result,
he became the most sought after Nazi scalped by postwar Nazi hunters.
He made the decision to flee Europe walking over the absence crossing into Italy
in April of 1949 he then made his way to south Tyrol wearing managed to obtain
an international Red Cross id card under a false name with sc.
Managed to get a Swiss passport,
then color then traveled to Genoa where he set sail for Buenos Aires,
Argentina.
Upon arriving on Argentinian soil,
Mengele finally felt safe.
He was taken in by Argentinean presidents.
One pair on and lived within his palatial compounds put on,
had been a longtime supporter of headlamp and it opened up his country to
fleeing Nazi's.
Manga established a comfortable life in Argentina.
He found work as a carpenter,
a trades at which he proved to be adapt.
He was also a highly respected member of the local Nazi community by now.
His father was extremely wealthy as a result of his business ventures.
The old man financed international run Davies.
Usually it's skiing resorts.
Absent from these family get togethers was mangle.
His wife Irene,
who had divorced her husband in absent Teesha on a family skiing trip to
Switzerland in 1956 man.
Hello,
charmed his dead brother calls widow Martha.
A year later,
they were married Martha Anderson.
Ralph moved to Argentina to be with Manga with the backing of his father's money
Mengele and his new family.
They lived very well.
They moved into an upmarket villa and a luxurious suburb.
Ironically,
in the midst of many wealthy Jewish families,
he felt so confident in his new life that in 1956 he gave up his and reverted to
his real name.
However,
a determined Hansville of Nazi hunters mainly made up of Holocaust.
Survivors were hot on his trail,
one of them harm and lang been managed to get ahold of the divorce papers filed
by Irene.
They indicated that men hello was living in Buenos Aires.
Lang been pressured the West German government to issue an arrest warrants,
which they did on June the seventh 1959 the West German foreign ministry now
demanded that Mengele be extradited to face the charges.
Mengele was warned what was happening and fled to Paraguay.
Yeah.
Later,
he'd moved on to Brazil where he settled in with a Hungarian couple on a small
farm,
about 300 balls from Sao Paolo.
In mid 1962 he moved again this time to a 45 hack to farm.
That's Sierra Negra,
150 miles north of Sao Paulo where he boarded with the Strauss family and his
old age Mengele became arrogant,
surly and self centered.
He treated other people and there's his intellectual than just racial inferiors
in 1960 for a war crime trials and Mengele was held in absentee Teesha
throughout the course of the trial.
The gruesome details of his experiments where related often by surviving human
Guinea pigs.
As a result of these revelations,
he became a hated figure for the vast majority of West Germans.
By 1917 the efforts to get mangler extradited had petered out since he had
largely been forgotten of ask that you continue to live and unhappy life with
the stress of family.
It had grown to load them.
In 1976 he suffered a stroke from which he only partially recovered.
He finally,
Matt has ended in February of 1979 suffering a fatal stroke while swimming at
the beach and 30 yoga in Silva moments.
He took his last breath.
He never says a single regret about his actions at Auschwitz.
So I really hope you enjoyed that biographics video.
If you did,
don't forget to subscribe to this channel for brand new biographies every Monday
and Thursday.
Also,
I've got another channel.
It's called top tens on that channel.
As you might've guessed from the name of us.
We look at all sorts of interesting top 10 lists.
You can check it out through the link on the screen now,
but if you're looking for something else to watch right now,
why not check out a biography from the archives or indeed a top tens video over
there on the right,
and as always,
thank you for watching.